yeah after that it was everything was
over and uh I guess that's when the
party started yeah I remember when we
were waiting to this water thing and uh
I was even cut like a little cousin or
something who yeah my little cousin this
kid this 10 10 11 year old Thai kid
speaks to me in like a Flawless American
accent and I and he was talking to me
and I was like how do you
how do you do how do you have an
American accent he's like oh what's a
lot of South Park and Family Guy and I
was like ah how would you say you were
again he's like I'm 11 I'm like all
right
then I'm sure that's good yeah you're so
funny yeah it is so cool God I'm like I
this uh being at this family gathering
being at this wedding kind of like
opened my eyes a lot because I talked
I've I talked to a lot of my younger
family members uh one I realized that a
lot of my younger cousins
um they all I was like they were like
initially they were like oh I watched a
lot of YouTube I was like oh that's
makes sense and then I talked to them a
bit more about who who they watch or who
their favorite content creators were and
90 of my cousins were like oh I watch
YouTubers
I remember that because one of uh your
cousins that was uh sitting with us for
quite a while was really cool kid uh
overheard that conversation and he
turned to me and he went what's a v
troop and I was like no no no no no
you are the last innocent mind your mind
will not be don't do it don't do it do
it to yourself it's like promise me you
will not look it up after this wedding
oh there was this really awkward moment
where I was having a conversation with
my cousin and my uncle was standing next
to him as well yeah and uh my uh he was
telling me about how he uh watches
YouTube and something like that and then
he says that he watches YouTubers and
then like a minute after that
conversation ends my uncle comes up to
me and he goes uh can you explain why
like his he's always spending this stuff
on his bank account I don't understand
like he's spending a lot on YouTube I
don't understand and I was just like oh
no no no no no no no no he's red
superher
oh no I was like oh no Uncle I don't I
don't know how to explain this to you so
there's this goal right if I did it
wouldn't help there's this girl been
real but they're not real yeah oh my God
but I also realized um I also had the
realization of why I am so adamant on
not taking pictures wherever I go and I
realized this because it's it's kind of
like maybe like a kind of trauma I
already know what you're gonna say maybe
like a kind of trauma that has stuck
with me and I this kind of like made you
remember why I hate taking photos it's
because every family gathering everyone
wants to take a photo and there is never
there is never an opportunity to not
take a photo yeah your aunt was going
insane yeah her camera roll must go on
for like years terabytes yeah because uh
because at this wedding I was like you
know taking a few photos and every time
and every single time I took a photo
like three more aunts or three more
uncles I just like okay can we take a
photo as well can we can we take a photo
and then so me and Sydney were posing
for a lot of the state I mean meanwhile
remember we're in like a full like Thai
traditional suit and get up and
everything yeah Sydney was like sweating
her ass off uh so we were just standing
there taking photos and as soon as we
thought we had a moment to breathe we'd
walk Five Paces and then someone would
be like can we take a photo can we take
another photo and we'd be like yes okay
okay you must yeah if you must and I
remember this was just how it was
growing up for me I I've grown up with
the sense that no matter where I go with
people someone's gonna take a photo so I
don't need to take a photo so this is I
guess I remember I remember now why I
never take photos it's because in my
mind I'm like someone's always there to
take a photo and there are going to be
way too many there's always an aunt or
an uncle around the corner ready to take
a photo yeah exactly I get that yeah but
I'm glad you guys got to see my house in
Thailand glad you got to see uh yeah
because I remember about that because I
remember like you were like all right so
uh you know meet up at the venue at x
amount of time and so you know we we
told the taxi driver to like take us to
this venue and they're taking us through
these like back streets and I'm like
yeah yeah where is this venue yeah and
then I realized your Venue is just your
house and I'm like why did you say venue
you could have just said house and I
would have been less confused because
along this road it was the weirdest Road
right because it's like I guess we
entered like kind of the the nicer back
streets where like there's like tons of
like huge mansions with like
extraordinarily like large ponds and
lands and stuff like that yeah and I
don't know if this is a thing in
Thailand but there were so many statues
of Pop Culture figures on the streets
that was there was a like there was like
a six foot bust of Captain America yeah
in front of someone's house I had to
double take so many times
Captain America's just his like from his
abs to his head yeah six foot statues of
that and then there was like this like
like maybe three or four foot tall like
Mario like porcelain statue yeah
um I I think it is just maybe not
traditionally part of Thai culture but
just yeah all right yeah we're just
sometimes you know Thai people
especially you know people around me
sometimes if you can just grab a cool
little like ornament or like artifact or
something like that no matter how out of
place it is you just put it there yeah
because I I remember I get a six foot
I'm like did you make that yeah because
I remember I I told that story to one of
your cousins and I told him about the
Mario one and he was like oh yeah yeah
he's a doctor yeah and I'm like didn't
even get Dr Mario
you [__] up like it doesn't explain
why he has a Mario in the front of his
Mansion yeah I think I think he just put
it like one of my other neighbors has a
[__] Jurassic Park theme yeah gate or
something like that yeah Titus and I
went walking in your neighborhood right
and we just walked past this gate and it
was I'm like I'm not tripping that's the
Jurassic Park logo on the gate and then
I look over at the wall and it clearly
says Jurassic Park and I'm like where am
I
yeah sometimes at least from you know my
family and people I know sometimes Thai
people especially when they're trying to
like build a house or put some cool
things or kind of try to get a way to
stand out they would just take a random
thing from America or British films or
whatever and just put it in the house
doesn't match the aesthetic doesn't
match the vibe at all sometimes you're
just walking past the house and you see
a random Mario statue doesn't make any
sense at all but that's just that's just
the way things are just like like your
neighbor's house that we started that uh
the the ceremony in like looked like
every country put into one place like it
was it was there was like a there was
like an Amsterdam inspired windmill next
to a river and then it was like a very
traditional like Southeast Asian house
and then there was just straight up like
a concrete block that looked like
something out of like like Eastern
Europe and I'm like what is this like
what's the theming
like how did the guy tell the architect
being like I want this I want this I
want this and the guy's like you want it
all in the same property right like yeah
it kind of feels like a dog park you
know because they're just like yeah just
so just have to have a little bit of
everything why not I thought it was a
theme park and then your cousin was like
oh no this is the neighbor's house I'm
like what does your neighbor do
it was insane it was very impressive it
was so weird yeah thankfully none of my
family served you boys uh Baron I with
ice cubes in there yeah I was expecting
it too though that I thought was
unacceptable well I was like could I
have a beer please and so he gives me a
beer it gives me a straw
a straw for a canned beer I was like I
was like no thank you what what is this
why do they drink beer out of a straw
what is that can you explain
um some people some people just do that
that's [__] up I don't know why what
the [__] beer out of a straw I think
it's [__] up as well uh yeah
I don't know I don't know I I don't
don't those own my guys
I don't think there was a moment where I
like in the 72 hours where I was in
Thailand where I wasn't disgustingly
full I think I was full constantly I
think every moment I was with these boys
because I only got to take care of these
boys one at my wedding and one another
day when I could show them around
um I think every hour I was with these
boys we were eating something because
everything's so good yeah everything
missed I remember at the wedding uh I
think your your aunt brought out these
like uh like sautes uh like chickens on
a skewer the chicken satay skewers and
they're a bomb dude I swear I saw Connor
eat like 50 of those like not not even
not even over exaggerating I think he
actually ate like four full plates of
that [__] I had a lot and they just kept
bringing them over I was like oh [__] I
can't let them get away see I thought
Connor wasn't eating much uh because I
was like talking to my family and
everything and every every time I'd come
to cut like your table Connor had a
false uh place
with Satay every time so I just assumed
oh it's the same plate no he was just
eating it so fast but you didn't see it
yeah and even though I was full they
started making other food and I was like
well I have to try it yeah the moment
you came back with the guitar
I was just I was so full and I still ate
a whole kapow and dude I the question I
got the most in Thailand every every
single [__] time I got any food they
were like are you sure it's spicy they
asked me this every [__] every food I
ordered they were like are you sure this
is spicy yes I'm sure give it to me on
the airline or any any [__] stall
yeah I've had Thai that wasn't even
spicy they're like are you sure it's
spicy I was like no it's fine I can eat
it I wouldn't have more than it if I
couldn't yeah but because like Thai
Thailand you just assume everything is
spicy I remember I took these boys it's
like a kind of like a casual place where
they serve like barbecue pork and some
chicken and stuff like that came with
three sauces
um and I remember Joey and uh diet is
asking me oh this is this like different
splice levels and I'd been in and I had
been abroad for so long so I assumed it
was just different spice levels and then
we were all like progressively trying
like the three different sources trying
to figure out which one was the spiciest
one right and then Joey was like oh I
think the middle one's the spiciest one
that is like I think the left one's the
spiciest one and then I tried it and I'm
like wait I think they were all the same
amount of spice I think it's the
difference is the sweetness of them
actually which just goes in Thailand
there's only one level of spice it's
just spicy it's just spicy Dom was
sweating non-stop yeah bro he was just
wet the the squid uh like dish that you
guys had at your wedding oh yeah the
spices yeah that was that was probably
the spiciest one I mean you know like
had a kick though but you know I I was
fine Connor was fine I guess didus
really likes squid yeah and uh and he he
put maybe half of his plate full of that
squid not knowing that it was the
spiciest thing dog author he finished it
he looked like he just came out of a
sauna
physically dripping he's so funny I'm
like are you okay did you just like run
a half marathon you look pooped
yeah I mean because I was telling this
to Joey earlier because I was I was
surprised I think Joey's got you've gone
on like a lot better handling yourself
compared to I surprised myself yeah yeah
because you handled a lot of the Thai
food pretty well I remember I remember
saying I think with Thai food there's
like a perfect amount of spice with
certain dishes people will just make
dishes with the amount of spice it has
that it has and you can last for it to
be less spicy but I think by asking it
to be less spicy or removing some of the
flavor out of it for sure you're also
asking it to be less tasty yeah you're
asking for it be less tasty they can
make it less spicy but the reason
there's always going to be a little bit
of spice in it even if you ask for Thai
food to be less spicy is because I think
there is just a perfect amount of spice
level for this food that makes it the
optimal taste and that unfortunately is
it's too spicy for a lot of people
um so good though yeah but it's so good
yeah oh man I was just full the whole
time